Musik Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast von Das Podcast UFO. Heute zu Gast sind nicht nur Stefan Tizipato und das Synonym für Erfolg Florentin Will, sondern auch Ingrid Wenzel. Herzlich willkommen im Das-Podcast-Ofer.
Dankeschön. Wir haben uns mal dazu entschieden, heute aus gegebenem Anlass eine Sonderfolge zu machen und Ingrid Wenzel einzuladen. Eine was? Eine Sonderfolge, die sich in den aktuellen Ereignissen äussern wird. Schön, dass du da bist, Ingrid. Ja, vielen Dank. Ja, immer gerne. Wir haben vorsichtig als Expertin eingeladen, ein Sommerloch zu füllen. Ach so. Das ist Basis sein.
Nein, wirklich. Man sieht ja wie du dein Sommerloch gefüllt hast, Du sitzt da wie so ein Echsenmensch, der sich gerade häutet und einfach mit den ganzen Beinen gebreitet, den ganzen Tag in jedem Meeting, beim Netto, an der Kasse, überall ständig sich die Haut vor den Rippenpool. Hautfelsen ist ihm runterfallen. Was ist passiert, Stefan? Also, ich war im Urlaub und leider war das Haus, wo ich war, sehr hoch gelegen, sehr nah an der Sonne gelegen, es war auch im Süden, und ich habe mich verbrannt. Sehr schlimm. Konntest du die Sonne anfangen? Am ersten Tag des Urlaubs habe ich mich verbrannt. Ich wollte zu viel. Ich war wie Icarus, glaube ich. Und wollte zu viel, wollte zu nah an die Sonne heran und mir habe ich einen Sonnenbrand davongetragen. und dann bin ich in die Apotheke am ersten Tag des Urlaubs gefahren und er hat gesagt, ja, diese Woche keine Sonne mehr für sie.
Was ein bisschen ärgerlich ist, das sind Sätze, die man nicht am ersten Tag hören will. Und ja, dann war der Urlaub furchtbar und jetzt langsam nach dem Urlaub fange ich an, mich zu pellen. Und es war so schlimm, dass ich einfach immer so hautfest hinter mir in der Herze ziehe. Aber na ja, da müssen wir jetzt alle durch. Das ist besonders für die Menschen in meinem Umkreis nicht so toll. Die wissen immer, wo du bist. Die wissen, wo ich bin, es tut mir auch sehr leid, dass du es jetzt so ansehen musst, dass du quasi durch mich durchgucken musst, aber naja, kann ich jetzt nicht machen. Ich war mal auf einem Larp, ich weiß nicht, wer das kennt, Live-Action-Roleplay, das ist dann, wo sich die absoluten Hardcore-Nerds, die in Pen-n-Paper-Roll spielen, Ladykiller, noch nicht hart genug waren und die einfach sagen wollen, okay, bin ich wirklich die grösste Jungfrau der Welt und einfach sich mit anderen Jungfrauen messen wollen. Die sind dann als Orks und Elfen und Zwerge verkleiden und irgendwo an einem scheiß Bauernhof irgendwie dann mit Schwertern durch die Gegend riefen. Angenommen, alle Jungfrauen kämpfen dann da mit Schwertern gegeneinander. Wer überlebt, ist es der best, der coolste noch unter den Jungfrauen oder die grösste Jungfrau? Der uncoolste eigentlich. Das ist schwer zu sagen. Der, der gewinnt, dann ist der uncoolste. Ja, auf eine gewisse Art. Und da sind wir dann rumgelaufen und da war es auch sehr heiß und die Sonne hat gebrannt, aber man konnte ja schlecht jetzt irgendwie anfangen, seine Bepanthel-Sonnencreme da rauszuholen, keine Ahnung wie die heißen. Bepanthol oder Bepanthel, du hast genau das Gegenteil. Seine Sonnencreme rauszuholen, weil es passt ja nicht ins Setting. Du kannst ja schlecht als Ork durch die Gegend laufen und dann mit so einem weissen Punkt auf der Nase dann irgendwie in die Schlacht ziehen. Das funktioniert nicht. Also White Walker vielleicht. Das kann funktionieren, ja, als Geist. Aber ansonsten haben wir einfach knallhart die Sonne abbekommen und es hat sich auch mein gesamtes Gesicht gepellt am nächsten Tag. Und da habe ich gerade einen Zivildienst geleistet und habe mit Kindern gearbeitet und kam dann so ein kleines Mädchen in die Zivilstelle rein und hat mich gesehen und hat nur meine Nase gesehen. Und angefangen zu weinen. Du mit deiner scheiss Nase. Einfach so mir direkt das Gesicht. Du mit deiner scheiss Nase. Einfach ja direkt. Da kam nichts mehr dahinter her. Wo man sagt, du mit deiner scheiss Nase kannst du bitte das Wasser geben, es kam nichts mehr dahinter, oder was? Ja genau, einfach das ist, so impulsiv sind Kinder, die einfach eine Beleidigung anfangen, ohne dass es irgendwo hin wird. Genau. Erst mal drei Wochen in den einsamen Keller gesperrt, knallhart ab. Hast du die schon mal so richtig gepellt, Ingrid? Nee, überhaupt nicht. Also ich bin, ich war einmal in Brasen, wo es 40 Grad war und ich habe mich vergessen, einzucremen und ich bin nicht verbrannt, seitdem habe ich gesagt, ich bin unsterblich. Das ist unglaublich. Ich habe einen Sonnenbrand bekommen, dann in Schweden, da war es 18 Grad. Du hast einen Schweden Sonnenbrand bekommen? Ja, da hat es mich dann erwischt. Aber wenn du jetzt die oberste Hautschicht verlierst, du hast ja irgendwie so drei Hautschichten oder so, so vierlagig oder so was in der Art, wächst dann eine neue Schicht von unten nach oder wächst dann oben drüber nochmal eine neue? Genau, die Frage habe ich auch gestellt. Rückt es quasi auf? Ich glaube nicht, weil die unteren Schichten sind wesentlich anders strukturiert, sind auch dicker teilweise. Und die werden ja nicht sagen, also die haben ja den wesentlich wichtigeren Job, die werden ja nicht sagen, ja, alles klar, ich gebe jemanden auf und muss als aufrücken. Also es wächst, glaube ich, einfach die Schicht nach, die beschädigt ist. Ja stimmt, vor allem, du kannst ja da nicht, also du verbrennst ja nicht deinen gesamten Körper,
deine gesamte Haut und dann könnte nicht teilweise die zweite Schicht zur ersten werden,
weil an anderen Stellen würde es dann hier wieder... Es wird halt in dem Moment interessant, wo man sich die Frage stellt, ab wann muss man zum Arzt gehen?
Und da gibt es nämlich drei...
Drei Denkschulen.
Es gibt drei Stufen, mit denen man unterscheidet quasi. Es gibt den Sonnenbrand ersten Grades,
das ist normaler, Sonnenbrand zweiten Grades, wo sich dann schon Bläschen bilden und Sonnenbrand
Aber Es gibt drei Stufen, mit denen man unterscheidet quasi. Es gibt den Sonnenbrand ersten Grades, das ist normaler, Sonnenbrand zweiten Grades, wo sich dann schon Bläschen bilden, und Sonnenbrand dritten Grades, wo sich die erste Hautschicht komplett auflöst. Ich weiss nicht genau, was bei mir der Fall ist. Zwei und drei, irgendwas dazwischen. Aber ich weiss nicht genau, wo man beim Arzt dann, wo man zum Arzt gehen sollte. Es ist halt echt, glaube ich, richtiger Sonnenbrand ist ganz schön hart. Aber die wichtige Frage ist ja, wird man danach weiss oder bleibt man braun? Hat sich das gelohnt oder nicht? Man hat mir immer gesagt, rot wird braun. Und ich glaube... Als allgemeine Regel. Als allgemeine Regel. Und deswegen hoffe ich, dass ich... Wenn das der Fall wäre, dann wäre ich nächste Woche aber Halli, hallo, oder wäre ich aber ganz schön braun. Ja, Moment, aber die Haut ist ja weg. Also wie kann die dann rot werden? Oder merkt sich die neue Haut das dann? Wir brauchen eine bessere Haut jetzt. Ich glaube, Haut ist ein sehr schwieriges Thema. Es ist einfach ein sehr undurchforschtes Gebiet. Es war ein sehr oberflächliches Thema. Wir hätten auch einen Dermatologen einladen können, der hat jetzt besser gemacht. Wir dachten tatsächlich, dass du Dermatologin wärst. Hast du dich denn schon mal im metaphorischen Sinne gepellt, hast du schon mal eine Lebenswandlung durchgemacht, bist du schon mal zu einem anderen Menschen geworden, ein prägendes Ereignis, durch einen Lebensabschnitt, durch einen Menschen, der dich verändert hat? Also vom Saulus zu Paulus. Oder vom Paulus zum Saulus, je nachdem. Überrascht mich. Also zu meinen Uni-Zeiten nannte man mich Ingo, das war mein alter Ego, das wilde Ego, und jetzt heiße ich nur noch Ingrid, also ich glaube, ich bin langweiliger geworden, definitiv. Und ich weiß nicht, ob es am Alter liegt oder wenn man irgendwann sagt, das reicht jetzt eigentlich auch. Du hast ja als Ingo angefangen, dann Inge und jetzt Ingrid. Nee, nee, Ingrichen, so nennen mich meine Eltern, aber das muss unter uns. Naja, ist auch egal. Es wird niemand.
Es trinken wir ein bisschen eine Pokémon-Weiterentwicklung.
Ingo, Ingrid, Ingrissimo oder so, der wahrscheinlich dann ...
Ingretti.
Ingretto.
Ingrid, wenn es Feuer fängt, ja.
Ingrid.
Aber du sagst, du hast, du sprichst es so aus, als hättest du zwei G, du sagst Ingrid,
oder?
Ingrid, das ist ja eigentlich falsch, wenn du NG sagst, da ist ja das G schon verbraucht. Sagst du mir jetzt, wie ich meine, nein, also manche sagen Ingrid, Ingrid, ne Ingrid, das ist ja eigentlich falsch, wenn du ng sagst, da ist ja das G schon vom Hau. Sagst du mir jetzt nicht mal, nein, also manche sagen Ingrid, ne Ingrid. Ingrid oder Ingrid. Ingrid oder Ingrid. Ja, aber Ingrid geht nicht. Also es ist eigentlich, also ich bin immer die Einzige, die so heisst, ist egal wie du mich aussprichst, also ich höre schon, wenn du schon mit ing anfängst, also du kannst auch England sagen, ich höre schon drauf, also, weil es kann nur eine geben. Okay, aber es ist ein sehr unüblicher Name für jemanden deiner Generation. Du bist 1996 geboren, da ist es natürlich sehr unüblich, dass man dann so einen Namen Ingrid trägt. Wie kam es dazu? Ja, müssen wir meine Eltern fragen, die ist eine erzkonservative Preussen-Bildungsbürger und die dachten so ein ordentlicher Name. Es gibt ja diesen Bundespräsidenten-Test, dass du guckst, Ingrid Wenzel könnte das auch Bundespräsidentin sein. Wie funktioniert der Test? Du kannst, du willst ein Kind irgendwie Chanel nennen und du denkst, Chanel will, könnte das auch Bundespräsidentin Chanel will? Klingt das oder klingt das nicht?
Bundespräsident Stefan Tietzel hat heute, morgen, ist heute Morgen hingefallen. Er ist über seine eigene Haut gefallen. Er ist von einem Klettergerüst gestürzt bei der Einweihung eines Kindergarten. Was macht er da drauf? Ja, na gut, aber du weisst ja nicht, wie sich die Bundeskanzler-Trends oder Bundespräsidenten-Trends ändern.
Also in 20 Jahren kann es ja sein, dass man gar nicht mehr vorstellen kann, dass die Bundespräsidentin nicht Chantal heisst. Das stimmt. Ich hoffe, dass wir auch noch... Wenn man da einer Barbara denkt, what? Aber ich muss bei Ingrid immer an so eine taffe skandinavische Wikingerfrau denken. Ja, also ich, das ist schon öfter zum Verhängnis geworden, mir meistens. Eine skandinavische Wikingerfrau ist dir zum Verhängnis geworden. Da hat man in Hamburg Probleme mit, ne? Richtig Probleme, ja. Hast du schon mal geplündert? Geplündert habe ich schon mal ge... ne, ist, ne. Aber ich habe, also die schlimmste Ingrid-Erfahrung war, als ich, ich habe auf dem Kreuzfahrtschiff gejobbt und musste dort Strickkurse geben. Ich kann nicht stricken, aber es hieß in der Board-Zeitung, also im Programmheft stand, Stricken mit Ingrid drin. Haben dann irgendwann die Gäste angefangen, dir Strickunterricht zu geben, oder wie lief das dann? Am Ende hieß es, Ingrid lernt Stricken von den Gästen. Genau, bringen Sie Ingrid Stricken bei. Weil du liest diese Board-Zeitung, da stehen so Highlights, Poolshow, umsonst Kuchenverspeisungen und Stricken mit Ingrid. Kuchenverspeisung? Keine Ahnung, also das ist ja so ein Highlight. Die grosse Kuchenverspeisung 2013! Als würden die Kuchen dich verspeisen, was auch ganz geil wäre, so ein riesiger Kuchen. Bisschen wie The Purge, so es gibt eine Nacht, wo die Kuchen dich verspeisen. Ja, klar. Wo du den gesamten Ärger und die Rache rauslassen kannst. Eine Nacht, da gibt esine Gesetze mehr. Ich glaube, so ist auch die Legende mit der Frau aus der Torte entstanden. Das stimmt, ja warst du auch schon mal in der Torte? Also du bist ja, also du hast ja schon viel erlebt in deinem Leben und du hast ja schon als Animateur. Ich war noch nie eine Torte. Du warst auch keine Torte. War noch keine Torte. Aber ist das eigentlich eine echte Torte, in der eine Frau drin ist oder ist das dann so eine Fake-Torte? Falls ich irgendwann mal das Angebot bekomme, dann muss drinstehen, das ist eine echte Torte. Ich fresse mich ja quasi durch, ich will ja auch was davon. Aber da ist ja eine echte Torte, also das wird ja ... Aber es klebt ja nie was dran, ne? Ich glaube, da ist eine Art Kastenkonstruktion drin. Aha. So, und darum ist eine Torte gebaut, was natürlich mir als aller Verbraucherexperte die Frage stellt, ist es überhaupt toll von diesem Kuchen? Ist es eine Mogelpackung?
Es ist eine riesen Mogelpackung. Die meiste Zeit ist hohl da drin. Wenn nicht gerade eine Frau da drin ist, ist es hohl.
Und dann hat man einfach, man erwartet von der Größe des Kuchens, wow, da muss es aber ordentlich Kuchen drin sein, aber da ist einfach so ein Kasten drin, das ist doch auch scheiße.
Wenn dann die Frau rauskommt, denkt man, okay, vielleicht war es das Pferd.
Kommt noch die Frau an, wahrscheinlich.
So viel zum Kuchen. Aber was passiert denn mit der Frau? Warst du schon mal bei so einem Ereignis, wo das passiert ist? Also dann kommt die Frau raus, dann ist es eine Stripperin und gibt es dann erstmal eine 20-minütige Stripshow und dann isst man Kuchen danach. Mich interessiert am meisten, ob man den Kuchen essen darf. Oder isst man den Kuchen während der Stripshow oder wird die dann erst nochmal angeschnitten von ihr oder das sind immer so Dinge so das ist so in den filmen sieht man oft so szenen und wie geht das weiter ja was passiert denn dann so das ist dann ja wie geht es weiter ich würde die grosse kuchenverspeisung würde ich vorschlagen aber das also was mich wundert dass da sich nichts pellt so wie bei dir also da ist da klebt ja kein kuchen an der frau ja so und das ist ja auch ein ein Stück weit schade. Ich hab mal einen grossen Kuchen zerstört, das war, das war, also an Highlights fällt mir das so in meinem Leben ein. Das klingt so, als hättest du einen Gegner besiegt, ich hab mal einen grossen Kuchen zerstört. In Level vier. Genau, mit vier Anläufen habe ich's geschafft. Da war ich Ingeborg, dreitausend Kampfmaschine. Nein, ich hab, das war auf einer Hochzeit, das war ein sehr reiches, sehr vermögendes Brautpaar, die haben wirklich da auf die Kacke gehauen und die hatten eine Riesenhochzeitstorte, die sie kurz angeschnitten haben und dann war die Hochzeit vorbei und dann wurde die weggeschmissen.
Und dann kam das Personal und wollte diese Torte gerade in so eine grosse blaue Plastiktüte nur so reinklatschen und dann bin ich so dazwischen gesprungen, nein, nein, und hab wirklich mit der Hand noch mal so in die Narben noch mal so reingefasst und das Stück ja in mein, also in mich reingepriggelt. Ach so, du wolltest noch ein Stück abhaben, du willst die Torte von dem Tod bewahren. Ja, alles für die Torte. Also Torten wegschmeissen geht gar nicht. Nee, was ist das für Schweine gewesen? Aber warum wurde die nicht ganz gegessen? Weil Hochzeiten sind doch ganz viele Leute da. Nee, das war repräsentativ, dann schneidet man ein Stückchen an und dann wollte es auch keiner. Ich weiss es nicht. Ist das auch völlig ... What? Ey, ich bin bald auf einer Hochzeit und freue mich eigentlich nur auf die Torte. Das ist das Heiler. Und dann wird die ... Ist das nur symbolisch oder was? Naja, das war nur so, hier guck mal, eine grosse Torte. Ah, das mit dieser Kuhnstripperin, vielleicht war die Idee ursprünglich, dass man sagt, man isst Kuchen von der Stripperin, so als zusätzlicher Gag und da hat dann die Stripperin komplett den Kuchen eingeschmiert, ist die rausgekommen und da dachte, das wäre so ein riesiges Yeti-Monster, weil niemand die Frau erkannt hat. Und da hätte man sich auch die Frau sparen können, da hätte es auch irgendwie ein alter Mann machen können, weil du siehst sie ja eigentlich nicht. Ich wollte gerade sagen, es muss ja nicht immer eine Stripperin sein, da müssen wir dann differenzieren, da lege ich natürlich auch Wert drauf. Ich glaube, es geht immer so weiter. Das heisst, erst war die Frau da, von der man ein bisschen Kuchen essen wollte, dann wollte man mal mehr Kuchen haben, hat man dann Kuchen um die Frau gebaut. Irgendwann will man dann wieder mehr Frauen haben, dann braucht man mehrere Frauen um den Kuchen, um dann da wieder einen Kuchen rauszubauen. Und irgendwann dachte man sich, brauchen wir die Frau wirklich? Und so ist dann der Kuchen entstanden. Der normale Kuchen entstanden. Die Evolution, am Ende hast du nur so einen Plunder. Wir können auch einfach kleiner machen und uns die Frau sparen. Brilliant. Oder wir stellen die Frau hinter die Theke mit ganz vielen Kuchen und die verkauft die dann so Plundertaschen. So ist die Bäckerei im Stand. So weit ist die Welt noch nicht. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Gibt die Welt noch zehn Jahre. 2080, mal gucken. Backt ihr, seid ihr backaffin? Ähm, nein. Biskuiteteig kann ich ganz gut. Okay, das ist mit dieser Rolle, da habe ich schon mal ein Desaster. Die Rolle ja, und Unterheben ist ganz wichtig. Ich war damals im Kochkurs eine Zeit lang mit einem Freund in der Schulzeit, einfach nur aus Spaß, einfach weil es einfach nur lustig war, ohne dass wir wirklich vorhatten, was zu lernen. Und da war dann ganz wichtig der Unterschied zwischen verrühren und unterheben. Ja, unterheben ist es eigentlich... Weil im Grunde ist es eigentlich dasselbe. Es ist halt nur so ein bisschen sanfter. Es bleibt fluffiger, schonen. Du versuchst halt, also du würdest halt die Blasen, die hier drin sind, diese kleinen Luftblasen, würdest du halt zerstören, wenn du das so wirst. Und beim Unterheben bleiben die Luftblasen erhalten und dann wird es schön fluffig. Auf jeden Fall das kann ich. Biskuit-Teig, und dann habe ich mit so Biskuit und dann so ein Blech und dann so ein bisschen Zucker drüber getan und einfach so weggesnackt oder halt die gute alte Rolle. Aber da musst du dann natürlich wissen, weil die Idee von Füllung ist ja so ein bisschen, dass die Füllung besser ist als der Mantel. Und das ist bei Biskuitteig finde ich schwer, dass wirklich eine Füllung zu finden, die besser ist als einfach nur Biskuitteig. Und deswegen habe ich es oft einfach so gegessen, weil ich dann, wenn du dann irgendwie so Sahne und dann so frische Erdbeeren isst, dann oft auch so semi-geil irgendwie und dann süßst du dann die Sahne noch irgendwie. Das ist dann immer so viele Komponenten, wo du am Ende denkst, ach weisst du, eigentlich hätte ich nur die Torte essen sollen, nicht die Frau. Das mit der Frau war, das war zu weit gedacht, das war zu lange gebrainstormt, irgendwie, das war einfach nicht nötig. Und so ist es beim Biskuitteig auch. Manchmal reichen auch einfache Dinge. Ist das so eine, was du dir gerade einredest, weil der Biskuit halt meistens schon weg ist, bevor du dir überhaupt Gedanken machen kannst darüber, was du da reinmachst? Nö. Nein? Nö sicher nicht? Nö. Hab ich über Fotos gesehen. Ja, aber diese Tortenböden, diese Biskuit-Tortenböden, oder? Die sind doch auch geil, die kann man doch einfach so essen. Ich hab die immer einfach so gegessen. Bin ich komplett raus. Nie gemacht, also diese so eingeschweißt sind, diese Tortenböden, wo man dann so Gelatine, Erdbeerkuchen mitmachen kann. Ich habe die immer so weggeessen. Ich bin auch kein großer Kuchenfan, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube, so sind nur Frauen entstanden, weil irgendwann waren Leute da, die wollten dann die Kuchen nicht mehr haben. Und dann gab es so etwas aus der Rippe des Mannes, erst der Kuchen entstanden und dann die Frau. Genau, ja. Wenn man Stefan kriegen will, muss man eher eine Frau vergiften als einen Kuchen. Richtig. Dann kann man ihn treffen, da wo es am Herdessen wehtut. Was magst du am lieben liebsten essen? Was magst du am liebsten essen? Ich wollte gerade auf die Frage, was magst du am lieben antworten, aber ... Ey, das ist eine sehr interessante Frage. Aber gut, zum weniger interessant. Was gefällt dir an der Liebe am besten? Auf der Zielgerade bin ich nochmal falsch ab in der Frage. Und dann nochmal zweimal falsch. Ich rede gern über Essen tatsächlich. Also ich esse, also wenn ich ein Gericht bis zum Tod essen müsste und ich lebe noch hundert Jahre, dann wären, also wenn ich noch einen Tag, egal, aber noch hundert Jahre, dann würde ich indische Linsen essen, jeden Tag. Indische Linsen? Da. Indische Linsen? Was sind das? indische Linsen, Linsen mit indischen Gewürzen auf eine bestimmte Datumweise zu bereiten. Das ist quasi die Spaghetti Bolognese von Indien mit, ja, also jede Familie hat da auch ihr eigenes Rezept. Indische Linsen, da. Habt ihr, oh na egal. Da kommen keine Frauen raus. Warst du ja schon mal in Indien? Ich war noch nicht, aber es steht auf der Bucketliste. Ihr? Was fasziniert dich an Indien? Das Essen. Ja, also ich kenne, natürlich kann man auch sagen, oh, ich interessiere mich für die Geschichte und die Kultur und Hinduismus, aber… Ja, das interessiert ja keinen, aber ich finde indisches Essen auch sehr geil. Indisches Essen war, war, das war so ein Pell-Moment, wo ich gemerkt habe, ach was, es gibt nicht nur Pell-Kartoffeln, wow. Ein Inder steckt irgendwie, der raus will, ja. Aber indisches Essen definiert sich doch nur durch die Dinge außenrum. Also das sind normale Gerichte und dann entscheidet man sich, ganz fancy Sachen zu machen, weil man hat Gewürze drauf oder man macht so eine Marinade drum, dieses Ticker-Zeugs. Was ich in der indischen Küche so interessant finde, ist, dass die es ziemlich verstanden haben, süss und herb zu kombinieren. Ich bin ein großer Fan von der Kombination, also auch so Schnitzel mit Preiselbeeren, immer richtig geil, so diese Kombination süss und deftig. Und da finde ich, machen die indischen Menschen, die Indianer, machen das dann schon sehr gut, weil sie dann auch zum Beispiel auch so Minzsoße haben und so süße Sachen und so dieser Joghurt ist ja auch viel dabei bei indischen Gerichten und dann auch so oft Zitronen und Orangen mit in den Gerichten drin, mit in den Körrelen, das finde ich richtig geil, das ist, mein Mitwohner und ich machen das immer, wir bestellen uns immer indisches Essen und schauen YouTube-Videos den ganzen Abend und das ist sehr schön, auch dieses Fladenbrot mit dem Knoblauch und so, das ist und Poppadom, so diese ganz dünnen, knusprigen Dinge, richtig gut. Hatte ihr schon mal indische Pizza? Nee, was ist das? Das ist quasi dein Chicken-Ticker-Kram, nur auf einer Pizza. Also es ist genauso geil, wie es klingt. Das ist nicht schlecht, aber die Amerikaner haben es ein bisschen vercheckt, ne, weil da heißt es ja wirklich Indien. Also die sind ja wirklich nach Amerika, also irgendein Volk sind nach Amerika gefahren, haben dann da entdeckt, okay, wir sind Leute, dann haben die die Indians genannt, obwohl sie genau wussten, dass sie nicht gerade Indien sind. Und diesen Fehler haben sie nie korrigiert. Das stimmt, das mit dem Korrigieren, das ist interessant. Die haben es nie korrigiert. Aber wie heissen denn dann Inder eigentlich? Ja, das sind Indiens auch. Und Indianer? Indiens, die haben es nie kor. Die heissen genauso, ja, ja. Die denken, die dachten irgendein Trottel, dachte, ah, wir sind Indian-Leute, scheiße. Ja, das ist mir schon klar, aber heute heissen die Native Indians, wenn du Indianer benennen willst. Aber warum sagen dann wir auch Indianer? Weil wir den Fehler, also die haben den Fehler erkannt, nicht korrigiert, komplett ignoriert, und wir haben es einfach auch adaptiert. Aber gab es dann irgendeine Umstellung, weil ich meine, die Amerikaner haben gesagt, ja, wir haben Indien gefunden und das haben die Deutschen wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen irgendwie und dann gesagt, ah, das ist Indien und dann aber nochmal. Dann sagen wir halt Inder dazu. Die hätten sich echt ein neues Wort reinfallen lassen können, aber das ist, ich glaube. Aber wie kannst du denn wissen, dass es Indien gibt, bevor du es entdeckt hast? Du kannst ja nicht suchen, was du noch nicht kennst. Wir haben Indien doch nicht vor Amerika entdeckt. Ja, aber die haben ja Indien gesucht. Wie kann man denn Indien suchen, wenn man nicht weiss, wo es ist, wenn es nicht weiss, dass es gibt? Es ist wie Narnia. Ich suche auch Narnia und weiss nicht, dass es gibt. Ich könnte es auflösen, aber ich lasse sie jetzt einfach. Ach geil, okay. Also die wurden nicht mal. Moment, aber die haben schon von Indien gehört und sagt, oh geil, da fahren wir hin, lass uns einfach mal hier nach Westen fahren, bis irgendwas kommt. Das wird dann schon Indien sein. Man kannte ja ... Aber wir haben die von Indien mitbekommen. Wie haben wir jemanden sitzen, der die Antwort weiss? Hey, ich habe dein Land gefunden, Indien, und dann gefragt, ja, ich habe das leider vergessen nachzufragen, wo es war, diesem einen Menschen, der von Indien weiss, deswegen fahren wir einfach mal irgendwo hin. Okay, die Antwort kommt jetzt. Nach einer kurzen Werbung. Jetzt. Kannst du nochmal schnell googeln, ich weiss, nee, also der Seeweg nach Indien wäre ja schon lange bekannt. Naja, die wollten nur einen kürzeren finden. Man dachte, man kann, wenn man andersrum fährt, vielleicht auch nochmal da hinkommen. Und dann kommt man tatsächlich irgendwo hin und denkt sich, ah stimmt, das muss ja Indien sein. Merkt relativ schnell, dass es es nicht, will aber das Wort, was man sich für die Indianer ausgedacht hat, nicht noch mal korrigieren. Aber warum haben die das nicht verstanden? Also wenn die
Indien schon kannten und wussten, wie die Leute aussehen, wussten, wie die sprechen, wussten, welche
Währung die haben, welche Kleidung die essen, warum haben die dann, als sie in Amerika
einkommen, nicht sofort gemerkt, Moment, Federn auf dem Kopf, kein Headset auf dem Ohr, kein Tech Support, jaha, boom! Haben keine Ahnung von der IT, wäre meine gewesen, sondern, ach man, dann wären wir die nicht Indiens. Das sind keine Inder, ja. Warum haben die das nicht gemerkt? Das war doch hier Columbo, oder, der Depp wieder. Erst macht er unser Vorabendprogramm kaputt. Ingrid, das stimmt auch nicht genau. Das war auch nicht hier Columbo. Sondern Polo oder was? Ich weiß nicht genau. Es weiß man nämlich nicht genau, wer Amerika entdeckt hat. Weil die Wikinger haben nämlich zuerst Amerika entdeckt mittlerweile. Ja, die Wikinger, das interessiert mich dann nicht. Die können sich alles sagen, ja, wir haben das vor euch entdeckt, aber haben es niemandem gesagt. Das behaupten nicht die Wikinger, das behaupten schon Forscher. Man hat ja nicht den überlebenden Wikinger gefragt, was der davon hält, wenn er in die Sache auf dem Larb, nein. Gut, okay. Alles klar, nur mit der Unwissenheit, man wird zu Ingrid überleiten. Das ist eine schwere Überleitung. Ich habe gar nichts, ich habe euch einfach nur reden lassen und habe genossen. Wie gesagt, Ingrid, Wikinger-Braut, meine erste Assoziation, du hast ja was Kriegerisches in dir und an dir, wo kommt das her?
Ja, muss man, das ist ja so eine Grundsatzfrage, ist der Mensch von gut aus, von Grund auf gut oder böse oder aggressiv, Wolf, die ganzen Schichtpunkte, Aber ich glaube, also ich wusste es ja selber immer nie, dass ich sowas Kriegerisches habe. Das merkt man ja erst, wenn andere halt nicht so sind. Also es war ja, du spielst bestimmt auf meine Bundeswehrzeit an. Wo hast du gemerkt, dass du zum Töten geboren wurdest? Also als du deinen ersten Fuchs erwürgt hast? Oder als du so? Oder als du mit der AK-47 erstmal ordentlich da den Iranern ein… Eben nicht, ich dachte immer, ich wäre nett und dann sagen alle meine Freunde, die bei der Musterung waren… Nee, du bist nicht nett. …sagen, das auch, aber nach dem Motto, also wir passen da nicht hin, aber dich Ingo, dich würden sie, du passt da hin und da habe ich erst gemerkt. Deine Freunde haben dir gesagt, dass du zur Bundeswehr gehen sollst, weil du nicht nett bist.
Nee, weil ich, also, O-Ton war, du bist doch so dominant, du bist doch so alpha.
Also geh zu dem Verein, wo man sich primär unterordnen muss.
Was ist das für eine Logik?
Das ist so sehr seltsam.
Ja, mit dem Ziel, nach oben zu kommen irgendwie.
Ach so, ja gut.
Also man kann sich ja auch ein Leben lang da verpflichten, in der Hoffnung, dass man dann irgendwann…
Aber wenn wir jetzt, wenn jetzt der Dritte Weltkrieg ausbricht, dann wirst du schon wahrscheinlich eingezogen, sofort. Ich bin keine Reservistin. Ja, aber man weiss schon, dass du es drauf hast. Wenn es brennt, dann werden sie sich natürlich bei mir melden. Dann werden sie fragen, komm, wir brauchen Ingo, gucken uns. Das heisst, es wurde dann gemustert. Es gibt ja, also ich wurde auch gemustert, die legendäre Musterung, der Moment, vor dem alle Angst haben, wurde der Arzt dann an den Hoden greift und dich auffordert zu husten. Gibt's da ein weibliches Äquivalent dazu? Da musst du eine Frau fragen. Nee, gibt's nicht. Nee, gar nicht? Nee, da gab's keinen in Erinnerung bleibenden Moment. Komisch. Komisch. Gott sei Dank musste ich das nicht das nicht mehr machen, wurde abgeschafft. Ich war der letzte Jahrgang, der das machen musste. Mhm. Ich hab's feierlich gemacht, so kann's gehen. Crazy. Und dann, wie ist es, Menschen in die Augen zu schauen und den Abzug zu drücken, langsam das Leben in seinen Augen löschen zu sehen? Cool, wenn's nur auf dem Bildschirm ist, aber … Ihr habt viel KaudValke gespielt, ne? Und FIFA, ich liebe FIFA. Genau, FIFA. Ich bin GTA bin ich. Okay, also du hast dann um den aufgehört, Soldatin zu sein, kein Bock mehr. Genau, ich habe Grundwehrdienst gemacht, ich war auf der Gorch Fock noch eine kleine Segeltour gemacht. Ernsthaft? Ja. Krass, aber da gab es doch diese berühmten Übergriffe, oder nicht? Ja, das war ... das war ... Zweite Weltkrieg meinst du? Ja. Nee, Moment mal. Wie, du ... du ... also das heißt, du warst ja Matrosin, oder was? Genau, ja. Das gehört zur ... Also keine Soldatin, also keine Infanterie-Klassiker oder gehört das ... Nicht mal Marine. ... erst nur so eine Standardausbildung. Ach, Marine war ich natürlich. Ach, Marine, sag das doch! Wir haben eine schöne Marina hier an Bord und dann sagst du das nicht, du alter Seebär. Mensch, ich komm doch auf, ich bin auch eine alte Wasserratte, du. Was machst du, paddeln? Du weißt ja, die Gorch Fock ist ja nicht gross, oder? Nee. Für ein Segelschiff ist es schon sehr gross. Ja gut, aber muss ja jeder Seemann einmal auf der Gorch Fock? Nee, nee. Es kommt darauf an, welche Laufbahn du einschlägst und ein paar Laufbahnen, da ist das obligatorisch. Es gab auch ein paar, die haben so Austauschoffiziere aus anderen Ländern, die haben das so als Geschenk bekommen und haben dann die ganze Zeit gekotzt. Also das ist entweder Bestrafung oder Geschenk. Und was war es für dich? Das war ein Geschenk, das war grossartig. Und was sind die krassen Sachen, die du da erlebt hast auf der Gorch Fock? Das ist doch bestimmt heftig, was du da erlebst. Also wenn das ist ein Schiff, das jede Zeit rumfährt, das die grossen Segeln hat und dann ziehst du dann, dann kannst du die Piratenflagge hissen und dann loslegen da. Das ist doch der Traum eines jeden Menschen. Also ich glaube, dass viele andere Rekruten mir widersprechen würden, weil es für sie halt eine anstrengende und eine furchtbare Zeit war. Ich fand es grossartig, unter dir sind Tausende von Kilometern, es ist nur Wasser, es ist so dieses schwarze Nichts, es ist nachts über dir nur die Sterne, es ist kein Motor, es ist kein Geräusch, du rennst nach oben auf das Segel, um das Segel einzuholen oder zu hissen, es windet und über die nur Sterne. Also ich habe sowas noch nie wieder erlebt. Dafür hat sich das gelohnt. Das ist cool. Und was macht man denn? Man fährt dann nur durch die Gegend, also zwischen Herfen, hinten und her den ganzen Tag.
Du fährst durch die Gegend und eroberst dann kleinere Handelsschiffe mit Kanonen. Aber hat die auch Bewaffnung, Keufock? Ja, Haiabwehr. Ja, erklär, geh da mal bitte näher drauf ein. Du kannst nicht einfach Haiabwehr sagen und dann zum nächsten Thema Toffefrie überleiten wollen. Aber das ist ein Riesenschiff, warum macht das eine Haiabwehr? Es ist ein Kriegschef offiziell, glaube ich. Kann Kann sein, dass sie sich geändert haben, ich bin noch im Stand von vor ein paar Jahren, als ich da war, als Kapitän Schatz da war. Aber was heisst denn Haiabwehr? Haiabwehr, wenn du reinfällst und da ist ein Hai, keine Ahnung, also es gibt Waffen an Bord. Ja, aber es ist nicht so eine Kanone, die dir direkt aufs Wasser zieht, oder? Es ist nicht so eine Plopp, so eine Kanone, ich weiss nicht genau, was für Waffen an Bord sind, aber wir haben Waffen, also ja. Ich weiss, dass manche Schusstraining an Bord gemacht haben. Also wenn ein Hai angreift, dann holt jemand irgendwie seinen Karabiner aus dem Schrank und schießt dann auf den Hai, oder was? Der Hai greift das Schiff nicht an, aber falls ... Haben die so eine Frisbee und dann fängt der Hai das oder so und bringt der Hai das zurück? Ach, falls jemand über Bord geht und dann der Hai angreift. Ja, hat sie doch gerade gesagt! Ja, ich war immer noch ... Ich stehe mir vor, dass die so grosse Stacheln haben oder so an der Seite. Du hast ein Haie-T-Shirt angezogen, also eine Haie-Kappe auch. Du musst ja immer zuhören dabei. Ich dachte, jetzt war Haie. Also die Gorkfork hat auch Indien entdeckt und wurde von einem grossen Oktobus angegriffen. Aber was sagt man, wenn eine Frau über Bord fällt? Sagt man dann Frau über Bord? Das weiss ich nicht. Oder auch Mann über Bord, oder was sagt man dann? Ich glaube, in dem Moment würde ich sogar meine ganzen feministischen Prinzipien nach hinten stecken und einfach irgendwas brüllen, damit jemand weiß, ah da ist was passiert. Du stehst Dinge, also es muss doch immer jemand da stehen und gucken. Hatte der Kapitän ein Holzbein? Ich weiß es nicht. Eine Augenklappe? Ähm, ne, aber... Aber war geil? Ein Widerhaken? Und welche Position hattest du? Ganz unten. Aber welchen Titel? Ich glaube, war ich schon Gefreite oder war … ich glaube, ich war noch Matrose zur See. Ach, man ist dann Gefreite statt Gefreiter oder wie? Ich glaube schon, ja. Also du bist dann Gefreite Wenzel. Genau. Gefreite zur See, ja. Und gibt's dann auch so Oberste statt Oberst Oberst oder so, also ist dann die Namen an die Chatten, Hauptfrau oder was?
Also es ist zum Beispiel Frau Leutnant zum Beispiel, Frau Kartheneleutnant.
Hauptfrau oder Frau Hauptmann?
Ich glaube, es ist Frau Hauptmann, aber es ist, bevor ich das Falsches sage.
Diese ganzen Begriffe sind überhaupt gar nicht für so eine Gendersache ausgelegt.
Er ist auch verrückt, also ich meine, in der ja millionenalte Kriegsführungsgeschichte der Menschheit ist es jetzt die erste Generation, wo Frauen auch mitmachen dürfen. Also mal abgesehen von Sowjetunion und so Ausnahmefallen und vielleicht bestimmt antike Amazon-Gedönse oder sowas. Aber die erste Generation, wo man sagt, ach stimmt, dieses uralte System, wir lassen einfach mal Frauen ran. Schon verrückt, die einzige Generation der Menschheitsgeschichte, wo das passiert überhaupt, erleben wir mit. Ja, ich glaube, da gibt es noch ein bisschen. Das ist die erste Generation an Frauen, die mitkämpfen darf. Ja, schön. Aber jetzt ist das normal. In 10.000 Jahren würde man sagen, ja, völlig normal. In 10.000 Jahren kämpfen nur Frauen, glaube ich. Aber man kann schon mit einem Segelschiff auch in alle Richtungen fahren, egal wie der Wind weht, oder? Da gibt es dann so Zickzack-Techniken und so, dass man dann auch gegen den Wind vorankommt, oder wie ist das? Ja, also man kommt schon irgendwie hin, genau, wie du schon sagst, mit Zickzack. Das ist natürlich auch die Frage, will ich jetzt... Aber die haben schon auch einen Motor, ne? Ja, ja, genau, so einlaufen, auslaufen, man versucht so lange wie möglich den Motor nicht zu benutzen, aber weil es auch cooler ist. Ja, das ist ja lame. Auch einparken. Mittlerweile wird das immer noch mit diesem Bugstrahlruder gemacht. Aber hat man da nicht Angst so aus dem Schiff? Also dann wirklich, dir kann niemand helfen, wenn das jetzt untergeht, hast du verloren. Ich hab Angst vor Wasser auch. Ich hab Angst vor Wasser eigentlich. Ja. Deswegen, also für mich war das schon, das war schon so ein, wieder so ein Pell-Moment auf jeden Fall. Ja. Können wir auch für ein, bitte, das Wort nochmal, aber das ist so ein schlimmes Wort, Pellen. Ja, das hast du eingeführt, ich hätte einfach sich häuten gesagt, aber Pellen. Sich häuten finde ich aber auch nicht wirklich besser. Ja, aber du häutest dich halt nun mal. Ich pelle mich. Warum häuten sich manche Tiere und andere nicht? Warum häuten sich Katzen nicht, dass dann einfach so ein Pelz auf dem Boden, der da diele liegt und dann einfach die Katze in der Kuhn hat. Ich habe überlegt, ich habe mich wirklich doll gepellt, ob man einfach so ein zweites Ich erschaffen kann neben mir, wie so eine Vogelspinne. Dass du dich selber ausstopfen.
Genau, und dann einfach hier zur Arbeit, dann morgens hinkommen, mein zweites Ich hinsetzen,
dann einfach so einen Motor am Kiefer befestigen, dass ich immer rede irgendwie.
Das ist ganz schnell.
Und dann mit dem Cartu-Go wieder wegfahren und dann gucken, was passiert.
Ja.
Wie Beffern ankommt bei den Leuten. Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Ich glaube, die Podcast-Hörer, UFO-Hörer würden viel Geld dafür zahlen, für diesen Beffern, für diese perfekte Nachbildung von dir. Jo. Jetzt haben wir gar nicht über Comedy geredet. Jetzt haben wir gar nicht über Comedy geredet. Schade. Du bist ja Comedian, aber was kann man von dir sehen? Ich bin Stand-Up-Comedian, ich habe schon ewig nichts mehr hochgeladen, einfach weil ich versucht habe, jetzt immer in kleinen Shows besser zu werden, kann man sagen.
Aber was sind so, also versuchst du schon, Deutschland zu revolutionieren, versuchst du, Deutschland zu infiltrieren und neu aufzubauen von innen heraus, ein neues Comedybewusstsein oder gehst du da ganz liberal dran, sagst du einfach, ich mache meinen Scheiss und will da gar nicht so ideologisch drangehen? Also ich glaube, jeder Stand-Up-Comedian muss auf seinen Kram gucken und in seinem Tempo nach vorne kommen, aber ich glaube schon, dass so unterschwellig bei allen Stand-Up-Comedians, die hier so heranwachsen, schon dieser Wunsch besteht, Deutschland wie so ein Entwicklungsland neu aufzubauen. Hast du das Gefühl, dass Deutschland gerade so einen neuen Wind bekommt, auch so aus Amerika, dass immer Leute hier hinkommen, die auch hier auf Englisch Stand-Up machen? Nee, Bill Burr kommt nach Köln jetzt im August, oder? Ja, Hammer! Genau, und Louis C. K. kommt nach Amsterdam, quasi Grossdeutschland. Aber hast du das Gefühl, dass hier gerade so ein bisschen so ein Aufwind entsteht? Also ich denke schon, dass so unsere Generation und die jüngere Generation sehr viel Netflix und Co. konsumiert und dadurch immer mehr. So wie diese Öffnung von Japan, wo die endlich gesagt haben, komm, wir gucken uns erst mal, was andere Länder machen an. Cool. Ich glaube schon, oder? Also den Anker lichten und dann ordentlich. Ihr seid ja auch USA-Fans oder? Voll der Kraft Backbord. Voll der Kraft, ja, auf jeden Fall sind wir USA-Fans. Also ich finde es auch immer falsch zu sagen, oh, in den USA ist alles besser und wir Deutschen, wir sind nicht lustig, das stimmt ja überhaupt nicht, aber generell zu gucken, wo machen das eigentlich andere Leute noch besser, ist kein falscher Ansatz.
Aber ich habe gemerkt, in manchen Situationen finde ich Comedy auch unangebracht. Als ich nämlich zurückgeflogen bin aus meiner Sonnenbrandinsel, bin ich geflogen und dann konnten wir irgendwie nicht starten aus irgendeinem Grund und dann kam der Kapitän, ein unfassbar lustiger Vogel, kam dann halt an dieses Walkie-Talkie-Gerät, hat sich vorne in die Kabine gestellt und hat einfach zehn Minuten Stand-Up gemacht, aber wo ich mir auch dachte, also je lustiger er wurde, desto mehr dachte ich mir, bitte fliegt das Flugzeug einfach nicht. Ja, du denkst dir ja, wie viel Kompetenzen spart er jetzt bei seinem Pilots sein ein. So, je besser er als Stand-Up-Kommission ist, desto schlechter muss er als Pilot sein. Ich dachte mir auch. War's gut? Was war's denn? Er weiß nicht, war ein bisschen abgefahren. Er hat die ganze Zeit auch so gesagt, dann waren wir oben und ja, wir haben uns unsere herrliche Reiseflugkurse erreicht und es ist ein bisschen, ist minus 70 Grad, wir haben die Birgärten mal zugelassen und so einen Scheiss die ganze Zeit überhaupt. Aber das ist das Niveau, was er komplett durchgezogen hat. Ich dachte, solche Witze gibt's vielleicht drei Stück. Er hat bestimmt fünfzig erzählt während des Fluges, er hat auch nicht eine Durchsage gemacht, als die Reiseflugur erreicht war, sondern irgendwie alle zehn Minuten und so. Es war wirklich auch ein bisschen anstrengend, weil auch der Film immer unterbrochen wird und so, wenn halt diese Borddurchsagen kommen. Alle waren schon irgendwann angepisst. Mega laut, Noah. Können wir einfach weiter fliegen, Mann ey! Es waren alle lustig, auch die Stewardessen waren lustig, da habe ich mich irgendwann gefragt so, ist das hier echt? Fliegen wir gerade wirklich? Comedy-Flugzeug? Comedy-Air-Berlin war das, ganz, ganz strange, ganz strange Flug. Und da habe ich mir auch so gedacht, da kam noch so das deutsche Bewusstsein in mir durch, Comedy gehört nicht irgendwo hin, wo es nicht eigentlich vorgesehen ist, wo du wirst. Weil man hat irgendwie dann das Gefühl, irgendwas ist gerade schief, irgendwas läuft gerade, bin ich träumig, was ist das gerade? Ja, Lachen bringt einen aus der Fassung, ne, also viele haben ja Angst vor dem Lachen, weil das ja was … Hast du Angst vor dem Lachen und Wasser? Ich hab Angst vor dem Lachen und Wasser … Deswegen hast du dich in beides gestürzt quasi. Genau, deswegen muss man seine Ängste ja mal begegnen. Nee, also ich finde, ja, Comedy-Kontext, ich finde es schlimm, wenn Leute nie lustig sein können, aber ich finde es noch schlimmer, wenn Leute nie ernst sein können, ganz klar. Okay, das war, glaube ich, eine unterschiedliche Kritik an uns. So, und jetzt habe ich mich noch mal geantwortet. Warum? Wir haben über sehr viele ernste Themen gesprochen. Wir haben über Krieg gesprochen, wir haben über Krebs gesprochen, Hitler gesprochen, über Marco Pola haben wir gesprochen, die Lieder, Frauen aus Torten. Für mich war alles dabei eigentlich. Willst du noch was ansprechen? Du kannst dir Leute erreichen, du kannst dir was bewegen. Du kannst dich mit jemandem grüssen, wenn du möchtest. Endlich hört mir mal jemand zu. Ja, nee, alles gut, danke für eure Zeit. Ja, klar, immer gerne. Vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Danke, liebe Ingrid. Ingrid Wenzel! Und wir heben, weil wenn wir UFO sind, heben wir immer.